we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
have you guys ever heard of
prosopagnosia
that's too science from can i try to
guess what it is say it again
prosopagnosia
it's when you get pegged too much but
you're
four oh oh because it's probably oh so
no peg no no you're like pro is pros yes
pro so peg so yeah so you get yeah yeah
or the sia part can you guess what that
means uh sia the actress
the singer the singer yes you would know
what i studied in this field is
psychology yeah
oh my god i started psychology and we
poked all normal [ __ ]
oh i don't know where in freud that's
how you know my mom wrote my papers
i don't know if the e or the u goes
first and freud eagles first
eagles wait does it no r
no no i know it's r but after that
including the argument ed the the id the
super
the the ego and the super eagle they're
[ __ ] but he's talking about the
spelling the eru she's talking about the
spelling of it how do you say that
r-e-u-d yeah so many brains in this room
when none of us know oh you're talking
about
freud how to spell freud yeah oh you
said eud okay yeah i said eud my bad
when you said ego i thought you meant
ego like e-g-o
i never said eagle she said e i never
said ego or eagle
i thought you said where the e goes when
you said that
freud ego right and i'm like well the id
comes before that i like that you were
going with it you were like i'm gonna go
with this stupid crazy [ __ ] why not
i can't spell it either i just i just
wait for the squiggly line to show up
and then i right flick i don't know
paper clip would fix it
come on paper yeah is it freud or is it
fruit paper because that shit's
old yeah i know listen i'm young
but i know a lot of things i researched
back in the day i think that's why we
get all your references because we're
probably the same
yeah we're all like really young you're
not 21 too are you no i'm 22.
okay so you're older than this yeah yeah
it's really weird
thank you guys for having me here as
your elder all right so back to the
prosopagnosia is the inability to
recognize the faces of familiar people
typically the result of damage in to the
brain so it's kind of like it's a
something along the run i thought it's
like when you like to hang a lasso
around your neck while you're jacking
off what is that called oh the auto rock
fixation oh okay what's it called david
carradine
oh yeah yeah no wait is it really called
that
no but that's how he did you know i know
i know but i just didn't know if that's
what it was called i'm like that's
[ __ ] morbid i just said oh but i have
no idea who this is
i just assume everyone that dies that
kill bill david carradine
the old guy kill billing that's pretty
good still billing yeah that's pretty
good
he was killing his bill when he died he
killed a little too hard these people
they see people
already and then they go wait who are
you but then like i've met you many
times
yeah so this one chick she's a 29 year
old russian woman
i'm gonna tell people i have this name
lena so
she only learned that she suffers from
this particular thing last year but
she's a cam girl and she can't recognize
her customers
[Laughter]
that's so convenient this is a very
convenient disease yeah what's the
difference between this
and like dementia or something because
isn't it like the same dementia i don't
know what happens with dementia what's
the difference between this is just
being a rude [ __ ] who doesn't
remember you met somebody i've dated
guys like this where i'm like it's like
so cool you're like oh it's very
convenient you don't remember people's
names
yeah so dementia is like uh it's
impairment
of memory loss and judgment but
no but this other one is you just don't
remember the face
yeah yeah she can't even recognize her
own that's why you have to like
but she can recognize bodies you have to
come to her naked you wear a bag over
your head and she goes
under she goes those nipples what i've
seen those tits on pornhub that's a call
back to another
yeah because she has nudes it's actually
on our patreon so go check out join the
patreon these guys
listen money is what we need these times
okay that's how we can get on our island
with kim kardashian you can hear her her
story on patreon
so i can hear my depressing story on
patreon
but anyway yeah she can't even recognize
her own face that's crazy
she was saying so throughout her whole
life she's always had these symptoms
like
headaches migraines low blood load blood
pla
what low blood pressure pressure having
a stroke too much pressure for her to
say pressure right yeah dude but she
said prostamagnosia
yeah perfectly well we don't know we've
only heard her say that that's true
could be something else
yeah i don't know there's a lot of
issues prosopagnosia
prosopagnosia prosopagnosia anyway
so she had that and then nausea and
so she she just had all these health she
must have been like thank god i'm not
pregnant
well she does have a kid and even with
her she'll recognize her kids no
get hurt segways
well i'm glad you brought that up she
does have a kid she does and so
she'll remember who the [ __ ] that is no
she's pretty yes that's great this is
lina
every morning you go like oh who's she i
hope so right
yeah so this is lena and so she doesn't
recognize her husband her husband she
doesn't recognize
take fifty-first that's so sweet does
she recognize that skull shirt though
is that why only faces right and so she
says the only way that she
she can really differentiate between
people that she knows
is through voices so that's how she's
able like
she remembers the voice so if you want
to rob this woman get really good
at faking voices yeah yeah so then when
she picks up her kid from school
she only knows it's her kid because he's
running to her saying mommy mommy and
that's how she knows that that's right
that's
weird to be like a sightful blind person
yes i pull a word it sounded so cute
very sightful you came in pretty
confident
well i know you weren't going to correct
me
i was talking to joe i think we would
have used i would have used it i was
doing that for
for fun of it oh okay okay exit yes yeah
i'm leaving
but yeah so she says she recognizes
voices but also she tries to
focus on certain irreplaceable features
like noticeable moles scars tattoos or
crooked noses
she says for herself yeah yeah all the
imperfections
are your insecurities yeah why did you
get that mole removed man
[ __ ] crooked nose guy i knew that was
you oh
she doesn't hang on to facial hair or
like like hair because
it changes so frequently like someone
could have their hair up and she won't
recognize him oh
damn she's like a baby for herself
she says when she looks in the mirror or
when she sees a photo of herself the way
that she understands that that is
her is um by the mole that she has above
one of her eyebrows the shape of her
hairline and by the scar on her chin and
the shape of her nose so she
she knows like she memorized what her
facial features are
is that why she got the nose ring i bet
you that's why right did she grow up
with everyone calling her dumbass
well she did a bit people were like you
[ __ ] that's actually something she
mentions yeah because she says like
people will be walking down the street
and they'll get upset
with her because they don't because she
doesn't say hi to them right she could
have gotten taken advantage of so hard
if people know about this
they should get poked in the eyes a lot
as a kid or something why is she still
rude though she could just say hi to
everybody no so she does
everybody that's not the russian way
though you gotta be pissed all the time
oh true you can't be smiling at people
because then they think you're going to
be like
crazy yeah but no for her though she'll
like she will say hi
if they say hi to her but she's just
like i honestly don't know like who you
are who are you who are you
like that happens to me sometimes yeah
cause i'm famous
not because i'm forgetful it could be
both things right
that is funny like when people get mad
at you and you don't remember them it's
like isn't this on you
if i don't remember you just weren't
memorable the [ __ ]
be more fun i'm like people don't no
one's not remembered me i'll just tell
you that okay
i'm loud and very annoying yeah you have
a lot of
significant moles too she would
recognize you i didn't notice that's bad
wow she's like all those hairs coming
out of your witch molds
crooked nose no i'm wearing a mask this
is
a halloween this week i don't know what
this is going to offer you're the [ __ ]
i find them like beauty marks you're the
[ __ ] to yourself wait what the [ __ ] you
called them significant moles
no they really are pronounced they're
like skin tones
don't fall into the trap tip don't fall
into it it's all jokes don't fall in
you know you have moles that take up
your whole face really that's what she
meant to sort of a mole
to the point where we don't even trust
you like you're a mole whatever
you're hideous i said thank you
i like to be nagged that's what you're
doing
oh yeah i'm egging an egg egg i like to
egg the egg
well yeah that's lena's condition and a
lot of people
that so for her the reason why she felt
so important to come out and like talk
about her
condition is because when she was a kid
she always felt ashamed
for not knowing or recognizing she
should be rude ass [ __ ]
she always like she just she didn't know
that it was a condition
she was just like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me i'm broken poor girl
so then she wants other people to know
like hey you know this could possibly be
something you have if you experience
similar symptoms
like you already told me that i think
it's really dope but
like right now this generation at least
has access to the internet and like we
have all this information on our phones
and there's a bunch of
tick tock instagram and [ __ ] about
people just talking about whatever
conditions and [ __ ] that they suffer
because then it's now
they start like building this really
cool community of like oh [ __ ] i'm not a
[ __ ] weirdo i do that too
i kind of like the olden days where like
the only problems you have were like you
had fleas or something
no no these just like they didn't know
what the [ __ ] any of this [ __ ] was so
they go they put up that's crap
they put a brain spike in your they put
a brain spike in and they're just oh you
fixed it
thank you can you recognize people now
[ __ ] okay they just try to pray the
demons out of you
and if you don't change they'll just
[ __ ] put leeches on you
guys seeing the show wretched i haven't
seen it yeah it's good
yeah so there's this one like so they're
talking about how they used to
lobotomize people like this one kid that
was in the hospital he would just
daydream
and his mom took him into the hospital
because they wanted to fix the
daydreaming out of him and they
lobotomized him you probably just had
adhd or something
oh so he was just daydreaming yeah and
then they just cut that's anything peace
out did you hear the [ __ ] salem witch
hunt like why they were having like
their ticks and [ __ ] they felt like
[ __ ] was crawling in their skin
because they had lice so the rye that
they would eat so they would make bread
and the right that they would eat
uh they just had a gluten intel
intolerant no they started growing mold
on it
so then when they would consume it they
got high well it had the same
um uh what is it like the chemical is
like lsd
yeah the chemical makeup of la's lsd so
they were just tripping balls but
at least the barnington was kind of fun
i would hope so
this is weird if they ate enough rye
bread before yeah yeah they probably was
sober by then
oh no they were tied up they're like can
i have some more bread
you